the european parliament approved the new
digital covid certificate
it will facilitate eu travel by ensuring
travelers have one of three documents
proof of vaccination a negative pcr test
or proof of recovery from covid19
parliament discussed the new 2030
biodiversity strategy
and demanded that at least 30 percent of
eu land and sea areas be kept wild
the aim is to reverse biodiversity loss
due to climate change
like the decline in pollinators
the 2021 lux audience award went to the
romanian documentary collective
meps and european citizens each had 50
of the vote
meps said a 5 billion euro fund to help
eu countries face the consequences of
brexit should be dispersed quickly
they wanted to support small businesses
and fisheries dependent on trade with
the uk
as well as job creation and the
reintegration of eu citizens coming back
from the uk
following a petition demanding the
phase-out of cages for farmed animals
parliament called on the eu commission
to come up with a proposal to ban the
practice by 2027